it's Christmas which means I got a new
sonic screwdriver 8th doctor this time I
got myself a nice set of TARDIS pyjamas
I got some Star Wars rebel insignia
earrings oh and that's right new Doctor
Who Christmas special twice upon a time
the last episode to be written by Steven
Moffat the last episode to feature Peter
Capaldi our first look at Jodie would
occur as the doctor there's a lot to
unpack here oh and yeah David Bradley
actually playing the first doctor in the
show itself as opposed to just you know
kind of a making of behind the scenes
desk kind of thing so yeah I guess my
overall feelings because I will get into
spoilers you should know that they're
they're a bit mix there's a lot there's
a lot of things there's a lot of moments
a lot of little things that I like a lot
and there's a lot of other things that
bugged me there's nothing that I hated
there's nothing I was like oh god but
there were a number of things across
that I was like but um I mean I like to
start positive let's start positive
Peter Capaldi was very nice he was sweet
I like that they really kind of
continued the through line of one of the
best moments from the doctor Falls which
was him talking to the master and saying
you know I do it because it's kind I
feel like they really held that as a
through-line from that episode to this
one and I like that a lot I especially
knowing how harsh he started out during
his tenure I really like that that is
like the note and the core of where he's
ending I like that a lot David Bradley
does really good work as the first
doctor that's not a huge shock he was
really good in an adventure in space in
time so yeah kind of expected that
coming Mark Davis was good I usually
like him as an actor and he was um it
was much gentler he was he was more
likeable because
market he he kinda usually has an
inherent smugness that works really well
for characters he kind of want to punch
in the face but he works really well as
Mycroft Holmes he works really well as
the guy from the iron bank in Game of
Thrones because even the very few times
we've seen him it's just something about
that smarming as he comes across like
yeah I totally get it this guy is so to
have him be a much more flat-out
sympathetic character was a nice change
of pace and I thought he did it really
well the revelation that it was the
father of Brigadier lethbridge-stewart
not a huge shock because I think most
people whether they had figured out
early on that this was a world war 1 or
a world war nor had mistaken it for a
world war 2 era I think everyone was
kind of assuming it was gonna be some
kind of connection to the Brigadier so
Wow nice it wasn't a surprise but the
show didn't really play it like it
surprised II there was more of a let's
just confirm what people are already
thinking kind of things so that was fine
as far as that goes the callback to into
the Dalek that was interesting I didn't
see that one coming
and I'm glad I'm glad that they that he
did have the line um you know that says
when I was miniaturized and went inside
you just could I was thinking that was
what was going but honestly it's been a
while since I've watched that episode I
really need to go back and do series 8
again it's been a little while but I
like thought that but I was kinda like
maybe maybe not any said oh good thank
you I don't have to google that now so
and and I I think that's just a nice
touch then it's not banging you over the
head with what this is like we remember
the reference like this is what it is so
we're not being obtuse because there's a
lot of stuff we can pull from there it
is you know what was something I loved
this we got the doctor's theme and when
I say the doctor's name I mean the track
from series 1 with Christopher Eccleston
called the doctors theme just that that
high range soft mysterious vocal
I haven't heard that in the show in a
long time and I that was awesome what
first time I caught that because they
use it a couple of points in the episode
first time I cover mine oh I'm like I
liked it so much that I almost kind of
want them to bring it back and have it
be judy Whitaker's doctor's theme I
don't think I actually want that though
because then you know it's no longer
Christopher Eccleston 'he's doctors
theme and then he has to share it so she
should have her own theme but i liked it
so much that I was like can we have it
back please so that was cool the whole
idea and the concept of the testimony
first of all it's a neat idea but the
more I think about it the more I really
really like that
it wasn't anything the doctor had to
stop I mean that's that's just nice and
because it's the narrative of Doctor Who
is such that I mean you kind of assume
he has more laid-back outings every now
and then but you not just assume there
are often um you know references to
adventures we don't see him have you
have to assume some of those are more
laid-back than others but you know what
we see is usually him finding like beta
know alien problem and dealing with that
so for him to stumble across something
that you didn't know about it appeared
secretive and is completely benign
benevolent even its retaining the
memories of the dead so that they are
preserved that there's no downside to
that and I even loved this reaction like
it's it's not an evil scheme I don't
know how to react to that but I just
love that because you know you watch
Doctor Who enough it's like God is the
universe ever not just screwed up does
he ever stumble across anything nice and
here he does and to have that be
especially on a Christmas episode and on
a regeneration episode where he's kind
of you know he's questioning whether or
not he's going to allow himself to
regenerate so sort of having that
affirmation that look there's
stuff out there too like that's it's
nice and again I just like you
conceptually that he stumbles across
something and it's fine there's nothing
there's nothing he has to fix like the
only problem that he has to fix is to
put this guy back and the only reason
the guy was out of time was cuz of what
he did it's a minor fix and even that he
makes better cuz he moves him forward a
little bit in time for the Christmas
thing which was a nice that was a that
was a cool way to bring the Christmas
angle in with the Christmas armistice
and like so that was a nice touch and
and again a lot of just really nice
little thoughtful things that I enjoyed
quite a bit bill coming back I was a
little more mixed on I wasn't negative I
was very skeptical on it because I've
railed before at the whole bringing back
companions after they've had their exit
and I don't mean necessarily strictly
bringing the back from the dead but like
they had their exit they left the show
and you're undermining that leave
because you're bringing them back and
the show kind of has it both ways
because it has the whole it's not really
her it's for preserved memories so it's
a good enough representation of her that
it that we don't have to we don't have
to like have her suddenly go with like
yes I am a duplicate up bill nothing
like it can be her and act like her but
it's also not really her so it's not it
doesn't feel like it cheapens her exit
as much it's still it's a little bit of
a cheat but it's what I'm prepared to
roll with so that that was enough to
take the curse off of having Bill come
back the moment with Clara I was fine
with I imagine that fans who really like
Clara of which I am NOT one but I
mentioned the fans who really liked
Clara there were probably waterworks
when that happened when he got his
memories back of her and that was a
sweet moment again it didn't hit me
personally because I've never loved
Clara but it was well executed and again
I imagine if you did really liked Clara
that that probably hit you real hard so
you know props to that the doctors sort
of little bits of rambling speech toward
the end were
okay as much as I am NOT a big fan of
the time of the doctor I do like Matt
Smith's kind of exit speech there as
time has gone on I've gotten more
critical of David Tennant's reluctance
like right up to the last minute but I
like that
capaldis moment is basically for
projection giving a lecture to who's
coming next I like that there were
things that it felt like the whole like
children can know your name thing like
it it sounds nice but I'm like I doesn't
mean is that supposed to mean anything
or is that just supposed to be kind of
cute and poetic and I'm not sure and I'm
not sure it matters but it just it it's
like right on the border of pretentious
and I'm not sure if it tips over into it
or not the stuff that didn't quite work
for me as well there there's a few
things that I don't have an inherent
problem with pointing out past errors
issues of previous incarnations of the
doctor particularly in terms of his
attitude towards other people so
pointing out that the first doctor was a
bit behind the time certainly by modern
standards and a little bit misogynistic
I don't have a problem with pointing
that out and kind of hanging a lampshade
on it cuz well yeah he was a little bit
but regardless of whether or not you
have an issue with that
as with having them pointed out and
acting like it's a bad thing or whether
you don't even want to point it out or
all at all or even if you like it being
pointed out the number of times the same
joke got made in very slight alterations
that got old for me really quick and I
imagine that there's probably a certain
stripe of fan that is losing its damn
mind right now going see see the agenda
which I don't buy I've never bought that
argument
what I will grant is any issues that you
have or that you believe in regards to
what you think is or isn't being pushed
that's just that's just clunky way of do
of doing anything cuz you're just
beating a joke to death so even if the
joke worked the first time you like just
stop please just stop so that that was
that was a little painful wasn't a huge
fan of that it took me a little while to
get into the story of it because I found
myself wondering like what why is this
why are we here what is going on and I
have had that happened to me actually
usually with with Christmas specials cuz
Christmas specials tend to be the ones
that diverge a bit more but also happen
to me with day of the doctor first time
I saw it so I suspect how that probably
won't be much as much of an issue on a
second viewing um but on the first
viewing I was sitting there going you
know this is kind of just I don't what
is our actual through what's our actual
plot to this besides just the doctors
being stubborn and stumbles across this
thing which and then I think it sort of
clicked for me a little bit more at the
end when I realize oh this isn't
something he has to fix this is this is
just a note that he's going out on and
once I kind of got there I was a little
more okay with it but watching it in the
moment like kind of through most of the
middle I was like I'm not entirely sure
where this is going and I'm not sure if
I'm what I'm supposed to be rooting for
cuz I didn't really know what the doctor
was trying to do fix whatever but he
didn't either so but it just kind of
made for a an awkward footing on a first
viewing um again second view I you might
like it better cuz that that I mean even
time of the the doctor which again I do
have issues with I liked better on a
second viewing because I understood what
it was doing much better that can throw
me off sometimes when I see an episode
and either don't get what it's trying
for it all or only figure it out at the
very end that means that for a stretch
of the episode I'm sitting there going
Wow
and then it comes in at the end and it
usually deserves a reward let's talk
about Jodie Whittaker okay first off
anyone who is looking at the one minute
that Jodie Whittaker is on the screen
and either declaring this is perfect we
love it and it's got to be great or
declaring this is awful and the worst
thing in the show is dead both of those
extremes please stop because you cannot
judge her her performance her
characterization or what's gonna happen
based off one minute you can't do it you
couldn't do it with ten and Sarah but
just off of Barcelona and you couldn't
do it for Smith Sarah based off just
Geronimo and you couldn't do it for
Capaldi based off of I've got new
kidneys I don't like the color you know
it's you can't you can't make a call off
that often times you look in hindsight
you go oh I can see what those early
what that actually did indicate but in
the moment you can't extrapolate forward
from that so I actually have almost
nothing to say about Jodie Whittaker
herself cuz June yeah I'll say this I
like the smile the smile the way that
smile grew on her face that felt very
doctor I'm like okay cool I'm like I'm
on board and that's not me going she'll
be great like I have no idea
we'll see the one thing I will say at
the end and this this bugged the heck
out of me I'm really really tired oh
there were generations making the TARDIS
go weird blow up you know whatever and
this was never a thing in classic who
but it's a big thing in knew who because
you know even Eccleston and that was the
most toned down one because he
regenerates into Tennant but then you
know the TARDIS crashes and it's acting
wonky and it's not working right because
he's regenerating and then Tennant
practically blows the entire frickin
thing up when he regenerates into Smith
right after Smith regenerates into
Capaldi the thing is almost immediately
crashing and now we've got Capaldi into
Whitaker and it's it's blowing up again
mmm like at this
point it's it's lost whatever impact it
has it at this point you're just going
why are you going inside the TARDIS and
damaging everything have your frickin
regeneration outside and then come in
it's become cliche and it's a cliche
that I don't even understand why it
exists I don't know why that keeps
happening it just it's and it's a really
lame cliffhanger to end us on until we
get to the next doctor because I mean
that dad they didn't really use that as
a cliffhanger coming off of Eccleston
but they absolutely did from Tennant to
Smith and then from Smith to Crowley you
know do you know how to fly this thing
basically implying well they're gonna
crack like and find a different way to
end the the regeneration episodes it
doesn't have to be a cliffhanger the
cliffhanger is we want to see what this
new doctors like that's enough of a
cliffhanger this weirdly contrived and
now the charm is a boy why hey I know
like in the big scheme of things that
small that's small potatoes but I really
did bug the ever-loving heck out of me I
guess one other minor thing I also feel
like there should have been more to the
fact that both Capaldi both the the
twelfth doctor and the first doctor have
just come off of dealing with Cybermen I
feel like that should have factored into
things somewhere and it it just didn't
I'm not sure how it could've but I just
find it odd that it that there was no
way in which that had an impact that
that had anything to do with anything
and that just strikes me as odd I
suppose the last thing I'll say is that
it's fairly typical in multi doctor
stories that whatever is the older
version of the older meaning the earlier
version of the doctor is always kind of
a little you know when looking at his
new form
I like the extreme that it went to in
this case because it's the first doctor
he has an
didn't regenerated at all yet and he's
seeing this extreme that is so far on so
many levels down the line from where he
is and being borderline horrified by it
just who and but again it almost
certainly is a missed opportunity
because it I feel like there is a vague
undercurrent of him seeing his future
self like this and wondering God should
I allow this to happen and hearing
phrases like war doctor and seeing so
many things he finds fundamentally
distasteful about Capaldi's version and
I can actually questioning should I
allow myself to regenerate or should I
just put a stop to all this I feel like
there's an undercurrent of that but if
it feels completely under dividing into
it I feel like it's a vibe but I feel
like that's something that should have
been explored especially considering how
well they pay off the plant of war
doctor cuz you think we are sorry doctor
of war because you hear dr. Ward you
think war doctor you think all the
horrible stuff that he did that he wants
to forget but he gets turned around and
he's given a new meaning by the end
that's really nice and I wish that had
been tied to a better understanding for
the first doctor of himself and his
future and what his place in the history
of the universe will be so that strikes
me as quite a bit of a missed
opportunity so I'm not I need to watch
this again before I figure out where I
would stick it in my overall ranking of
the Christmas specials it's probably
somewhere in the middle maybe upper half
if I'm being honest it's it's pretty
good and I'm not I'm not the biggest fan
of the Christmas specials anyway but
it's pretty good it's pretty decent and
the more I think about it the thing it's
one of these things where the more I
think about it the things that I like I
like more the more thought that I put
into it like yeah yeah but like I said
there are some missed opportunities
there's a couple of just clunker moments
so it's it's by no means flawless it's
it's probably kind of middle-ranking for
Moffitt's work as well which means now
that I've seen this getting into the New
Year I will finally be able to do my top
ten on my bottom ten rankings for Moffat
written episodes so you have that to
look forward to in the new year
um I think that will just about wrap it
up
os boson toss this in as a bonus if
anybody's curious the Eighth Doctor
screwdriver visually very similar to a
third and fourth doctor's function
slightly differently because so third
and fourth doctor they have the slightly
bit this just has a button so just the
button on the back which means you do
have the multi sounds and now it's not a
ton of them it's not like some of the
newer ones where it's like eight
different sounds depending on how many
times you click it but you got yours
that's your two basics it switches
between those on one press you do three
presses which was also a feature on the
eleventh Doctor's but also if you do
four or more you end up with sort of
this staticky one that I'm actually not
sure is supposed to be there but it's
just kind of it so it sounds like it's
struggling which again it it sounds so
often I'm almost like is that meant to
be a function but I mean regardless I
like it cuz it sounds like it's
struggling as a piece of equipment so I
think that's cool so latest addition to
the collection hope everyone had a great
holiday whether you celebrate Christmas
or not if you're watching this I'm
assuming you at the very least watch the
Doctor Who Christmas special I hope you
enjoyed the holidays you know I did I've
got Christmas colors going on so what
were your thoughts on twice upon a time
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it do
all the things like subscribe I'm on
Twitter I've got a podcast there's links
for all that stuff down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]